India China
there's a lot of uh animosity those two
countries have for each other okay and
it's it's a very obvious India is the
only one that publicly banned 100 apps
from China in India okay Tick Tock being
one of them
India is I think taking 25 of Apple's uh
iPhone being made over there Tim Cook
decided to move 25 over there I want to
say it's 25 or it's going to be 25 but
they're moving a lot of the
manufacturing over to India
India's uh the the starnu produced the
best Engineers have been doing this for
a while with their school IIT Institute
which some people say schools mits who
have been there it's an incredible yeah
set up that they have it's it's on a
whole different level people keep hiring
Indian engineers and they're fantastic
on what they're doing yes the reputation
that they've had over the years on
business is gradually changing 30 years
ago 40 years ago 20 years ago 10 years
ago it's changing where trust is going
higher around the world Modi is a
pro-capitalism uh uh you know supporter
you know on what he's done obviously
he's not a perfect leader he's got his
own flaws like everybody else does but
he's he's done some great work in a
country with 44 different political
parties I don't know what the number is
but I think it's 44 give or take
political parties he's done a good job
on bringing him to where they're at
right now
what what what do you think is what do
you think of China what do you think of
India how important of a role India is
to keeping the world uh uh not relying
on 100 of China where China can impose
themselves on everybody else
and the only reason brought up India and
China is because you worked in those yes
I worked in India I did not did not work
on China but obviously I I watch it I
think we we have to deal with both I'm
and I'm a Believer in typically an
engagement not because I think it's soft
but because I think if you don't want to
use military power and you say you don't
want to talk to somebody
where do you end up like I would say you
gotta engage with the Iranians you have
to do it because of the Alternatives say
we walk over away from the table and we
have no capability to influence the
outcome well you're like Iran you want
to support the government that's not
what I said I said is here's got a few
options so I look at China which we can
talk about in a moment and I say I think
engagement and also understanding of
what the trajectory is in the 21st
century realistically if you look at
population growth economic growth
ability to plan decades in advance
ability to overlook when you're when
you're China and looking at African
elsewhere they don't care about human
rights we're just going to invest we
don't do that in this country in America
I think we have to figure out a way to
deal with China because if you want to
say we're going to compete with them
over Taiwan in 2035 I'm going to say
okay let's let's play that game I want
to see it gamed on paper how we're going
to do that and I want to make sure that
you know the American people are going
to support going across the Pacific to
do that so China is a different case
obviously in India I think I completely
agree on India when I used to work on
India in terms of economic regulations
in terms of global engagement in terms
of politics and diplomacy I thought
huge country huge potential as you say
educational capabilities at the upper
young 28 years old yeah incredible
um uh intellectual Talent investment
also and hard stuff like engineering and
Sciences
I think engagement economically makes
sense
politically in terms of things like
countering China I look at the attitude
of India on issues like
populism and human rights in the country
religious diversity
boy I'd be cautious I would be cautious
about getting too close in terms of
seeing them as a natural partner because
I think Moses who I think Modi does not
see the world in the way we do in terms
of what he sees for the future that's a
Hindu country it's not a multi-ethnic
country for him I think and that's going
to cause if you look at the History of
Violence ethnic and religious violence
in India I would not have High Hopes
about stability in that country over the
long term really I'm not talking about
Revolution I'm just talking about stuff
the government does where Americans in
Congress and elsewhere cringe and say
wow we don't want to be in bed with
those people I um I man
that country has a history of who who do
you fear more demo or China long term
China okay I wouldn't say fear I would
say uh if we think we can conformidable
enemies yes that's exactly right that's
how yeah that's right just just again
population growth economic growth
ability to plan investment in the
military and
uh geography if you look at access to
the Pacific obviously into Taiwan we
keep thinking you know we will defend
Taiwan good luck
good luck
and tell the Americans that we're going
to do that over the course of time with
the military and economics and a
population of that size good luck the
American politicians say it I want to
see it gamed out
yeah I don't think there's any uh
American fervor to go to war over Taiwan
and and and Biden once again I think
speaks said it though yeah but he's
again it's like when he when he got out
in front of Obama saying Obama supports
same-sex marriage a guy speaks before he
thinks
he said that and I'd say have you have
you wargamed out that in in The
Situation Room good luck especially as
the years pass and China keeps growing
and keeps investing
good luck 81 million people voted for
this guy to to lead the Free World and
so we we have to you know trust in the
fact that 81 million people chose him to
be the right guy to lead these types of
situations you know Biden but
unfortunately every single time he says
something people who voted for him keep
saying yeah but that's not what he meant
and uh he shouldn't have said that I
mean how many times you shouldn't have
to say that every day you should have
better things to do in your life than
say he shouldn't have said that you know
what I mean it's a little bit of a
challenge when you have to keep
defending the person that you support it
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]